in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
as the Prime Minister reaches a hundred
days in office this week having pledged
a government
[Applause]
having having pledged
having pledged a government marked by
Integrity what are his thoughts on the
UK being one of only five countries
along with Oman Azerbaijan Myanmar and
Qatar that has seen a decrease in
transparency International's corruption
index score since last year
Mr Speaker in fact there's wide
widespread recognition and support for
the UK's approach to transparency and
indeed tackling corruption indeed the
most recent report the most recent
report from the fataf body uh commended
the UK for the steps that it had taken
I refer to my entry in the register of
interests Arts Council England was
established to increase access to great
art for the population There's real
concern and anger that their current
funding decisions do the exactly reverse
of that on the basis of inadequate
evidence and a lack of transparency in
the process will my right or friend meet
with me and other concerned members to
discuss the situation in which centers
of national Excellence like English
natural are at risk of closure and
discuss the way in which we can reform
the operations of Arts Council which
many people no longer feel is fit for
purpose
oh Mr Speaker I know that this is an
issue that my honorable friend deeply
cares about he will know that decisions
made by the Arts Council are taken at
arm's length from government dcms
ministers have been assured but that
process was robust but I will ensure
that he gets a meeting with the relevant
minister to discuss this important
matter further without comes the leader
of the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
prime minister in his words about the
first minister of Wales and the sad loss
of his wife everybody I think knows just
how close they were and I know that he's
absolutely devastated by her loss at the
weekend
Mr Speaker when the Prime Minister
briefly emerged from his hibernation at
the weekend he raised more questions
than answers so in the interests of
integrity and accountability can he set
the record straight did his now form a
chair tell government officials that he
was under investigation by the tax man
before or after the Prime Minister
appointed him prime minister Mr Speaker
I appointed the independent advisor to
investigate this matter fully
he he has set out his findings in detail
over the weekend and on receipt of those
findings I took action and I referred
The Honorable gentleman to the
independent advisors report
[Music]
[Applause]
oh come on anyone picking up a anyone
picking up a newspaper in July last year
would have known for hmrc and the
National Crime agency were investigating
months before he appointed him Mr
Speaker the independent 6th of July new
chancellors finances secretly
investigated by the National Crime
agency the observer three days later 9th
of July revealed officials raised flag
over tax Affairs before he was appointed
Chancellor the financial times the next
day 10th of July pressure bills to
explain his finances is he saying his
officials hid this information from him
or was he just too incurious to ask any
questions
so Mr Speaker as I've said before at the
dispatch box the usual appointments
process was followed with respect to the
minister without portfolio and
no raise with me at the time of his
appointment but as the independent
advisor to report makes clear there was
a serious breach of the ministerial code
and that's why I took decisive action on
receipt of that report
[Applause]
so in relation to his former chair his
defenses nobody told me I didn't know I
didn't ask any questions
is the prime minister now also going to
claim that he was the order premises Mr
gullis we heard enough last week I can't
hear what you're saying I might not
be saying but I can certainly see your
mouth moving it'll be moving outside if
it continues prime minister
so for his former chair nobody told me I
didn't know I didn't ask any questions
is the prime minister now also going to
claim that he's the only person
completely unaware of serious
allegations of bullying against the
Deputy Prime Minister before he
appointed him
prime minister Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
The Honorable gentleman asks ask these
questions about what was known and I
followed due process I pointed
independent advisor as soon as I was
made aware of uh as soon as I was made
aware of new information the independent
advisors conducted this process but if
he is so concerned about what people are
saying and they're so concerned about
behavior in public life then recently
one of his own MPS was forced to speak
out because being in his party had
reminded her of being in an abusive
relationship
and then and then and then his own
office was caught undermining her
I'll be trusted to stand up for the
women in his party he can't be trusted
to stand up for Britain
but the last pout the Deputy Prime
Minister was facing 24 separate
allegations of bullying a according to
recent reports some of the complainants
were physically sick one says they were
left suicidal
how would he feel if one of his friends
or relatives was being forced to work
for a bully simply because the man at
the top was too weak to do anything
about it
Mr Speaker I I noticed he didn't say
anything about why one of his own MPS
describes being in his own party
and Miss Nipper when I was made aware of
formal complaints I instructed a leading
independent KC to conduct an
investigation because I take action when
these things happen but what did he say
at the weekend he said at the weekend
that hate had been allowed to spread
unchallenged in the labor party under
his predecessor he was speaking as if he
wasn't even there but he was sitting
right next to him supporting him for
four long years not challenging and it
is typical of him Mr Speaker declining
to lead sitting on the fence carping
from the sidelines
and and never standing up for a
principle that matters
I want to hear both sides and I'm not
going to have be interrupted by either
side and I'm particularly looking for
people who want to continue this because
we will sort it out today
speaker it's just like one of his
predecessors who treated questions about
conduct or something to brush off who
thought that ducking responsibility was
a perfectly reasonable response for a
parent at least In fairness his
predecessor didn't go around pretending
it was a paragon of integrity and
accountability
but on that subject was it a coincidence
that the two people who arranged an 800
000 pound line of credit for the former
prime minister were both shortlisted for
Plum jobs at the BBC and the British
Council
it's rigorous it's transparent it's set
out in a public code of conduct and
indeed and indeed was fully supported
not just by an expert panel members but
also by the cross-party dcms select
committee
including including where labor members
describe the appointment as impressive
but Mr Speaker Mr Speaker back back back
this week in terms of what is actually
happening to the people of this country
he voted he voted this week with the
unions to oppose minimum safety levels
he voted with just stop oil to water
down the public order Bill and what do
the unions and just stop all have in
common they bankroll him and his party
Mr Speaker
so while he sides with extremist
protesters and union bosses we stand up
for hard-working britons and school
children
foreign
trying to blame the labor party for his
failure to sort out the strikes is it's
rank pathetic
the Tory passes addiction to sleaze and
Scandal has done huge damage to this
country and the cost of the public keeps
adding up we've got a justice system
letting murderers walk the streets heart
attack victims working hours for an
ambulance an economy that's shrinking
quicker than his leadership
and even I couldn't quite believe it
when I saw that his government is
expecting taxpayers to pay the legal
fees for the member for Uxbridge
defending himself over his lockdown rule
breaking a quarter of a million pounds
surely even this prime minister can put
his foot down stand up to his old boss
and tell him he made the mess he can
pick up the bill
Mr Speaker he can't stand up to his
union bosses he can't he he can't he
can't stand up for Britain's school
children today
can't stand up for the women in his
party Mr Speaker
we're getting on we're halving inflation
we're growing the economy we're reducing
debt we're cutting waiting lists and
we're stopping the boat while he can't
even figure out what he believes in
we'll keep delivering for Britain
thank you very much Mr Speaker would my
right honorable friend agree with me
that the integrated care boards must
prioritize more access to new GP
Services especially in places like South
Derbyshire where new housing Estates are
being built at the fastest rate in
England and in particular on the New
Brownfield development of Draco
yeah well Mr Speaker the government is
committed to increasing the number of
doctors in general practice and last
year saw the highest ever number of
doctors except a GP training place the
bmar Consulting each year on the funding
of GP services and honorable friend will
know that the NHS has a statutory duty
to ensure sufficient medical services
including general Practice in each local
area
Mr Speaker I'd like to pass on my
condolences and indeed those of my party
to the first minister of Wales and also
to the family friends and colleagues of
firefighter Barry Martin who so sadly
lost his life following the blaze in
Edinburgh just last week
Mr Speaker we've just marked the
three-year anniversary of brexit and
we've learned so
cheering in a moment Mr Speaker because
we have learned we have learned three we
have learned three things the UK's three
deficit has grown the economy is being
hit to the tune of a hundred billion
pounds each year and of course and of
course we know that the UK's economy is
expected to be the worst performing of
all advanced Nations does the Prime
Minister still believe that the UK can
afford not to be in the European Union
here prime minister well Mr Speaker if
you actually look at it since the uh
since since brexit the UK has grown
exactly the same as Germany has uh Mr
Speaker but not only that we are taking
advantage of brexit deliver for the
people across the UK whether it's the
fishing and farming communities of
Scotland whether it's through the two
new freeports the
nouns the
Miss party in ours is that we respect
referendums
because let's let's be clear take
together 2022 and 2023 are expected to
be the worst years for living standards
since the 1930s and the economy is
expected to perform worse than sanction
hit Russia so as the brexit sinks
with the Prime Minister and the leader
of the opposition at the hill does he
blame those Scots who want to jump
aboard the independence Lifeboat
[Music]
the number one factor that is impacting
people's living standards inflation
caused by high energy prices as a result
of a war in Ukraine Mr Speaker it's got
nothing to do with brexit and that's why
the government is taking significant
action supporting every family with 900
pounds this winter but what I would say
to him is rather than obsess about
constitutional Arrangements focus on
delivering for the people of Scotland
that's what we will do David Johnson
yeah thank you Mr Speaker the baby
daughter of my constituents Gary and
Sarah Andrews died just 23 minutes after
she was born when they asked questions
about that the parents were told that
these things happened and that um if
they had to listen to the concerns of of
every mother they would be overrun
thanks to dogged campaigning by Gary and
Sarah and other parents whose babies had
died avoidably Nottingham University
Hospital's trust was found to have
systemic failures and last week was
given the highest fine that's ever been
given for
um failings in maternity care
does my honorable friend agree with me
that this case this situation has to
serve not just as a watershed moment for
having the highest standards of
maternity care
but also that when things do go wrong in
something like an NHS trust or another
public body they have to be open and
honest and transparent about their
feelings so that people can get the
truth and not have it hidden from them
well Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to hear
about the tragic case of honorable
friend raises and I know the whole house
will join me in sending our thoughts to
Gary and Sarah
we want to make sure that the NHS is the
best and safest place in the world to
give birth and the NHS has taken steps
to improve but cases such as the one
that my honorable friend raises
highlight that more must be done
Nottingham University trust is receiving
support from the expert maternity
Improvement advisors and nationally the
Royal College is implementing the
recommendations from the Independent
ockendon report together with 127
million pounds of extra investment the
modern friend is absolutely right when
situations like this do arise
transparency is Paramount so we can seek
answers and make improvements Caroline
Lucas thank you very much Mr Speaker
it's nearly 10 years since the tragic
death of nine-year-old Ella Roberta the
first person ever to have air pollution
listed on her death certificate
yesterday's environmental Improvement
plan pledges to improve air quality but
the government's targets of a 2040
that's a whole generation away I don't
think that's fast enough and neither
does Ella's mum Rosamund advocacy
Deborah so on her mum's behalf will the
Prime Minister agree to meet us both to
discuss the life-saving measures in a
new proposed bill called Ella's law
Mr Speaker it's obviously very sad to
hear the case of Eller and our thoughts
and hearts go out to her family with
regard to the legislation as uh Myron
front environment secretary will make a
statement later today we are confident
that the measures we are putting in
place are not only legally binding but
also World leading in tackling air
quality the record over the past 10
years is one where every single air
particulant has been reduced with
binding targets to continue reducing
them in in future and indeed the
environment act make sure that we have
the capability accountability and
ambition we need to make all the
effective interventions to drive down
air pollution not to learn false thank
you Mr Speaker compared to what some
people seem to believe 82 percent of the
jobs in our economy are in the private
sector compared to 18 in the public
sector most of those private sector jobs
will be in small businesses the small
businesses that we will depend upon for
wealth creation and prosperity in the
future will my right honorable friend
consider bringing in a small business
test across government so that every
regulation we produce every bit of
legislation we produce will help not
hinder small businesses and does he
share my ambition that every white van
man and woman and every white clo a
white coat Tech worker in this country
will regard the conservative party as
their natural champions
well my uh my right honorable friend is
absolutely right and this government is
proud to join with him in supporting
small businesses I'm pleased to tell my
honorable friend that we do have a small
business test to consider whether the
impacts of regulatory changes will
disproportionately affect smaller micro
businesses I will make sure that we are
applying that test rigorously and he'll
be pleased to know that many small
businesses will benefit from billions of
pounds and business rates reductions
this coming Financial year as well as
our annual investment allowance which at
a million pounds is the most generous
tax incentive for investment for small
businesses anywhere in the world I'm a
Gotham
Mr Speaker this morning just two hours
ago I launched the appg on prepayment
meters I did so because most people on
these meters are on very low incomes and
yet they pay more per unit of energy
than the Prime Minister does they pay
higher daily standing charges than the
Prime Minister they're automatically
disconnected from their energy Supply
the second they run out of money
and and perversely right now record
numbers of people are being forced onto
them by the energy companies can the
Prime Minister even begin to imagine how
terrifying that moment is when the
lights go out and everything shuts down
and will he agree with me rather than
breathing out please what he's got
written in front of them will he just
agree with me that what I've just
described is completely completely
unfair
well Mr Speaker the government does
recognize the challenges facing those on
prepayment meters and that's why the
government is taking action the
secretary of state has set out five very
specific points on prepayment meters
energy suppliers was being spoken to to
make sure that they treat customers with
the respect and flexibility that they
deserve and finally off gem have
announced that they are launching a
review into supplier practices in
relation to pre-payment meters but all
of this Mr Speaker comes on top of the
considerable financial support that this
government has provided to help people
with their energy bills with more of
that support being targeted at the most
vulnerable families in our society
McLean
thank you Mr
Mrs after 8 000 residents of Redditch
signed my petition to bring back
chemotherapy to the Alex the trust
reversed their decision to leave it at
kidderminster
a fantastic win for our town and I'm
grateful to the local acute trust for
listening so carefully and changing
their mind so does the Prime Minister
agree with me that it's right that the
acute trust can change its mind or the
provision of maternity and Pediatric
Services so that women can give birth in
our wonderful town of Redditch
Mr Speaker my honorable friend has
clearly been a fantastic advocate for
the Alex and for her constituents we
have awarded 10 and a half million
pounds to the local trust and I
understand that some of that funding is
being used to improve Maternity in
Pediatric Services at the nearby
Worcestershire Royal honorable friend
will know that these operational
decisions are being made by integrated
care boards and I know that she will
continue to make her views known
Mr Speaker if I had a pound for every
time I'd heard the prime minister's weak
excuses I'd be able to pay the chance to
former Chancellor's tax bill because it
was last July AI that it was reported
that the National Crime agency had
investigated the right honorable member
for Stratford on Avon the then prime
minister knew the media knew we all knew
it's inconceivable that the current
prime minister didn't know so why did he
choose to ignore it
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I appointed an independent
advisor to fully in
back that's the process that the party
opposite called for that's a process
that we follow
s Mr Speaker two years ago
30 ways to boost growth and make Britain
the most competitive country in the
world
so far we're underway with about half of
them but some of the most valuable like
reforming ponderous and expensive
utilities Regulators or building on our
International lead in open banking
haven't moved at all so will he meet
with me to discuss how to channel our
inner Nigel Lawsons and unblock the
arteries of our economy with low-cost
pro-competition supply side reforms
prime minister Mr Speaker honorable
friend has a long track record in
advocating for and implementing policies
that increase our competitiveness and
reform the supply side of our economy
his report was fantastic and I look
forward to meeting with him to discuss
them further and help Drive growth in
this country that's from worst Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker ambulance waiting
times are out of control my constituency
my constituent contacted me regarding
her 93 year old mother who lay collapsed
on the ground at home for 17 hours and
then queued for 13 hours to get into the
hospital and yet on Monday the Prime
Minister said he had his fingers crossed
that ambulance waiting times would be
reduced does he really think that's
enough
yeah well
well Mr Speaker if the honor ready
actually looked we published on Monday a
comprehensive plan to reduce wait times
in a e and with ambulances we're backed
with more funding and reform of the
system more beds more ambulances more
staff and and Mr Speaker it was a plan
that was warmly welcomed by all of those
working in emergency care and the
ambulance services they recognize that
this plan will deliver reduced waiting
times and improve care across the
country including in labor on Wales
where there are some things we can
benefit them from Jerome Mr Speaker if
you grow up in Norfolk and you want to
be a dentist the nearest place you can
train is in Birmingham or in London so
it's not really surprising is it that in
Norfolk we have a dearth of dentists
whether it's NHS or private
we also know that where there is a
Dental training school more dentists end
up working locally so will my right
honorable friend agreed to look again at
the benefits of establishing a Dental
training school alongside the excellent
medical school at the University of East
Anglia
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend will
know that there are around 400 dentists
with NHS activity in Norfolk and waveny
but he's right the centers of dental
development build on the existing local
infrastructure to help retain and
recruit dentists and I would advise him
to encourage his local integrated care
board to look at proposals for one of
those centers in his area very clearly
fought yeah yeah thank you Mr Speaker
the Prime Minister once said that he
didn't have any working class friends so
we may not be aware that today that
today is half a million hard-working
people are on strike including in his
own constituency yeah Tory Britain isn't
working
is the prime minister gonna get a grip
and negotiate with working people or
does he intend being remembered as the
PM who silenced and sacked hard work and
nurses paramedics teachers real workers
and firefighters in a cost of living
crisis
well Mr Speaker Mr Speaker when it when
it comes to teachers we've actually
given teachers the highest pay rise in
30 years includes a nine percent pay
rise for newly qualified teachers and
record investment in their training and
development I am clear that our
children's education is precious and
they deserve to be in school today being
taught and actually the party opposite
would do well to say that the strikes
are wrong and we should be backing our
school children
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
sadly suicide is the biggest killer of
young people under 35 in the UK
my constituent Andy Airy along with Tim
Owen and Mike Palmer are the three dads
walking
Andy Tim and Mike each tragically lost
their precious daughters Sophie Emily
and Beth to suicide and have campaigned
tirelessly through charity walking for
suicide awareness and prevention to be
included in the school curriculum I've
been humbled to support them including
joining them on their UK walk as they
came through penrith with their petition
which is due for parliamentary debate on
the 13th of March and with my early day
motion which has support from right
across the house
would the Prime Minister join me in
paying tribute to the three dads and
would he meet with me and the three dads
to discuss Suicide Prevention and
ultimately save young lives in the
future
well Mr Speaker of course I've paid
tribute to Andy Tim and Mike especially
for channeling their own personal
tragedies into such positive action to
prevent this happening to other families
that is inspiring and they deserve
enormous credit the government is taking
action to improve the provision of
Mental Health Services for young people
in schools and colleges but I would be
delighted to meet with him and Andy Mike
and Tim to discuss what more we can do
Ian Blackford
okay
[Applause]
thank you thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for that welcome
Ordinary People didn't need to hear an
IMF forecast to understand that the UK
economy is the worst performer amongst
the leading nations in the world they
live with it every day people know that
energy bills are through the roof they
know that 750 000 households face
defaulting on their mortgages well house
prices fall and they know that food
prices are rising at the record rate of
16.7 as of today the prime minister is a
hundred days in office his party 13
years in power in all that time does the
Prime Minister ever reflect that the
only thing that the Tory party has been
good at is pushing people into poverty
oh but oh Mr Speaker it uh it's
wonderful to hear from uh the right
honorable gentleman and uh I'd love to
see him in his place what what I would
say is that we're continuing to deliver
for people across the UK including and
in Scotland he mentioned poverty poverty
today lower than when the conservatives
first came into office inequality lower
than when the conservatives first came
into office and the number of people
the lowest on record
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker today in my
constituency there is a great sense of
shock and disbelief Following last
night's horrific dog attack that killed
a four-year-old girl the police
investigation is still going on and it
wouldn't be appropriate to speculate on
the circumstances but it would mean a
great deal if on behalf of the house the
Prime Minister could send our
condolences to the family and to the
community and to thank the emergency
services for dealing with the situation
with their customary compassion and
professionalism
prime minister well I thank my honorable
friend and send my condolences and I'm
sure the whole House's condolences to
the girls family and the community after
this horrific incident and I joined him
in thanking the Emergency Services they
have responded rapidly and
professionally and I know that my
honorable friend himself will be
supporting them and his constituents
during this difficult time Christine
Charlene uh thank you very much Mr
Deputy speaker this past week
[Applause]
time can I blame the pain can I blame
can I blame the painkillers
apologies Mr Speaker and thank you
um this past weekend I uh visited a
charity which was hosting an exhibition
in my constituency about metastatic
breast cancer
um which claims 31 lives each day in the
United Kingdom and the women there asked
me to convey at the first opportunity to
the government the need for more
awareness more support more research and
more drug availability
can I ask the Prime Minister if he will
do that if he will help to bring that
support but also I have written to the
Scottish government asking for their
support if in his next meeting with the
first Minister he would mention it to
her
oh Mr Mr Speaker can I pay tribute to
the charity that The Honorable lady
mentioned for the work they do she's
absolutely right awareness is key in
tackling and identifying breast cancer
symptoms early one of the reasons why
we're investing more in Diagnostic and
screening tools to make sure that we can
detect more cancers earlier and treat
them and ultimately save people's lives
I I would be happy to pick up this
particular topic with the first Minister
when I next speak to her and ensure that
we are working together to improve
cancer services for everyone regardless
of where they live in the UK yeah
uh thank you Mr Speaker in the United
Kingdom government's negotiations with
the EU regarding the Northern Ireland
protocol would the Prime Minister kindly
confirm to the house that the
sovereignty of the United Kingdom and
its four nations will not be compromised
Assurance I know this is something that
he cares passionately about the
implementation of the protocol is having
an impact if the communities in Northern
Ireland that's why it needs to be
addressed and that's what we are
attempting to do through constructive
dialogue but the goal in that must be to
ensure Northern Ireland's place in our
precious Union Kim Jones Thank you Mr
Speaker since the election of the
fascist Israeli government in December
last year there has been an increase in
human rights violations against
Palestinian civilians including children
so can the Prime Minister tell us how he
is challenging what amnesty and other
human rights organizations are referring
to and a Parc side state
well Mr Speaker The Honorable lady also
failed to mention the horrific attacks
on civilians inside Israel as well and
it's important in this matter to remain
calm and urge all sides to strive for
peace and that's very much what I will
do as prime minister and in the
conversations that I've had with the
Israeli Prime Minister Sir John pays
final Mr Speaker in uh 2016 the British
people had the wisdom and foresight to
Take Back Control
[Music]
from foreign lawmakers and when they
when they did so they believed we were
taking back control of our borders yet
since that time we have faced wave after
wave of illegal migration so will my
right and old friend without further
delay bring forth the necessary
legislation to turn back the time and
fulfill the promise was made to the
British people then yeah well Mr Speaker
my honorable friend makes an excellent
point that's why one of this
government's five priorities and
Promises to the British people is indeed
to stop the boats we will introduce new
legislation that makes it unequivocally
clear that if you arrive in this country
illegally you will not be able to stay
we will swiftly detain you and remove
you to your own country or a safe third
alternative that's the right and
responsible way to tackle this problem
complete questions
well at the end of prime minister's
questions let's just bring in our
political editor Beth Rigby uh kistama
really pushing the Prime Minister on
Dominic Raab and on allegations I mean
within the party yeah Jane what you saw
there were there six questions two on
the Doom Sahari two on Dominic Rob two
on Boris Johnson so it's all about uh
starma trying to press home allegations
of sleaze and Scandal and then making
the point that the Prime Minister isn't
standing up to that and that was not
comfortable uh for Mr suno particularly
around the issues of Rob because even if
you can argue that the Boris Johnson
stuff isn't the responsibility of sunac
or indeed the Nadeem Sahari as Rishi
sunak claims that this was happening and
people were not aware according to the
independent investigation around Mr
zahari's Tax Affairs the issue about
Dominic Robb is straight at his door
because there are accusations that the
Prime Minister was informally made aware
of some of these allegations about
you know unacceptable Behavior by Mr Rob
and he didn't act on it we're going to
go back to the comments because an
urgent question from the labor party
about the Hillsborough report
thank you Mr Speaker
so Ashley Holmes second Teddy the home
office will make a statement on the
National Police response to Hills where
families report
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I'm
extremely grateful to The Honorable
member for his question I know this is a
subject with very profound personal
resonance for him and I pay tribute to
him and many others for the work they
have done and continue to do in memories
of the victims of this awful tragedy and
to ensure the lessons are learned
the Hillsborough disaster was an awful
devastating tragedy its impact continues
to be felt to this day especially by the
families and the friends of the victims
I'm sure the thoughts of the whole house
are with them
I learned from the experiences the
Hillsborough families have gone through
so I am very grateful to Bishop James
Jones for the report he produced
highlighting a number of points of
learning for the government for the
police and for other agencies
as my writable friend the Home Secretary
said yesterday during the debate
um the government is fully committed to
engaging with the hills Hillsborough
family's prior to the publication of the
government's formal response and I can
also say
um that in particular since arriving in
the home office uh two or three months
ago and I've asked for this work to be
sped up and we are expecting
and we are expecting it to come out in
the course of this spring
uh Mr Speaker the National Police Chief
Council and the College of policing
published their response earlier this
week I welcome their commitment to
avoiding uh repeating the mistakes that
were made and for the apology which they
gave they made clear that strong ethical
values the need for Humanity and
humility in the police response to
public tragedies is critical and one of
the commitments they made rightly
earlier this week is to substantially
strengthen and update their own Code of
Ethics in relation to these issues
and Mr Speaker
um there have been some very important
steps made uh by the government in the
last few years responding which which
have addressed a number of the points
but not all of the points which Bishop
James Jones uh published for example in
February in 2020 a suite of police
Integrity reforms were introduced on a
statutory basis via the Professional
Standards for policing which included
critically a duty to cooperate with
inquiries other initiatives have been
taken forward to support bereaved
families already including the removal
of means testing for exceptional case
funding to cover legal support for
families and inquests which broadens the
scope and access for families and
refreshing our guide to coroner services
for brief people so it's more tailored
to their needs and it provides improved
guidance for others involved in the
inquest process the inquiries act 20
2005 also provides a statutory process
for funding legal representation
requests last year the home office also
established an independent pathology
review and additional consultation with
the families is now taking place a
consultation has also taken place on
retaining police documents which was the
subject of a recommendation made by the
bishop and the ministry of Justice have
also consulted on establishing an
independent public Advocate those steps
I think are important they go a long way
towards improving the situation but they
don't cover everything of course that
the bishop recommended which is why we
will be responding in full our
intentions to do so this spring but
after of course full and deep engagement
with the families concerned uh Mr
Speaker the government is committed to
making sure these lessons are learned
following this awful uh tragedy and I as
the newly appointed police Minister will
do everything I can to work with members
across the house but particularly those
members representing the affected
communities to make sure this does now
happen quickly
in the
since that all for today on their 15th
of April 1989. 97 people died directly
from the actions of South Yorkshire
police and other agencies including the
Emergency Services the fa and CFO
Wednesday football club but families
destroyed and survivors traumatized
so traumatized that many oceans take in
their own lives the lives in smears from
The Establishment covered up erected
with impunity and arrogance because they
could meant Justice was never delivered
for all those who died and suffered
since in 2017 Bishop Jones delivered the
report the patronizing disposition of
unaccountable power a report to ensure
the pain and suffering of the
Hillsborough families is not repeated
shamefully we have not yet said the
government response to his
recommendations to report commissioned
by the then prime minister The Honorable
member for maidenhead
Bishop Jones yesterday said the delay
was intolerable
his recommendations are in essence the
hills below but so many in this place
and outside of sins campaigned for
we must always remember these
recommendations are to ensure no other
community go to the sufferant we've
endured since 1989. they hopefully
future proof the ability to gain Justice
yesterday we finally had the response to
the report from the College of policing
and the National Police Chiefs Council
this was the first apology
from the police force for this actions
since the disaster 32 years ago for so
many including myself it's far too
little and far too late
yesterday's recommendations from the
police did not go anywhere near far
enough to change the culture we came up
against in our quest for justice so I
asked the minister will this government
do the right thing for future
generations of our nation and Implement
a Hillsborough containing Bishop Jones's
recommendations with immediate effect
the families and survivors of so many
disasters and consequent State cover
options they have nothing less than
these injustices must never ever be
allowed
if a Hillsborough that existed in 1989
we wouldn't have had a chance of justice
for the 97 without it we had no
minister
well I fully I stand and respect the
sentiments that The Honorable member
just so powerfully expressed in his in
his remarks in relation to the timing
um and the the years that have passed
since the Bishops report
um for much of that time there were
ongoing legal proceedings and of course
nobody wanted to Prejudice those for
obvious reasons that accounted for about
four years from not 2017 uh to around
about May of 2021 but 20 about 21 months
have passed uh since then and I agree
that this does the government response
uh does need to come out quickly it's
something that since my appointment
um a couple of months ago
um I've asked to get sped up and I want
to try and make sure that happens uh
this spring but following of course
consultation with the families that
obviously is extremely
um important and that will include uh
responses to the point um points that he
he made and but I would just reiterate
that the
um the statutory changes made to the
Professional Standards for policing in
2020 uh do include a duty of cooperation
on police officers in relation to
inquiries which was is a very important
thing as he's as he said already but he
is right we do need to get on and
respond comprehensively um to the
Bishops recommendations which is what
I'm working on Theresa thank you Mr
Speaker the apology from the police is
of course welcome but frankly it would
have been far better for them to have
done their job properly on that fateful
April day 34 years ago if they had done
so families of the 97 and indeed the
whole Liverpool Community would not have
gone through the suffering and anguish
that they've had to Bear over the last
34 years can I say first to my right
honorable friend
saying vaguely that the government's
response will be available this spring I
do not think is good enough
Five Years on the government must
publish its response but will he agree
with me that one of the elements that
can be put in place to help families who
if sadly such an event a tragedy of this
sort happens in the future is the
introduction of what was promised in the
conservative party Manifesto in 2017 of
an independent public Advocate and will
he commit now that the home office will
not put any barriers in the way of the
work of the ministry of Justice to
introduce such a body
and well I thank my writing will friend
for her question I mean as I mentioned
um for about approximately four years
since the Publications report there were
ongoing legal criminal legal proceedings
which nobody wanted to Prejudice but as
I have said in the house and as the Home
Secretary said uh yesterday we do want
to now get on and quickly respond
comprehensively to the Bishops report in
relation to the independent public
Advocate a measure being
worked on by the ministry of justice as
the right lady said a consultation a
public consultation has taken place on
that and the response is being worked
through in the usual way but it's
happening at place
she had a Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank my
honorable friend member for West Derby
and also all of the merseyside MPS for
pursuing this and securing this urgent
question 97 people lost their lives as a
result of what happened at Hillsborough
on that terrible day 34 years ago and we
remember the football fans who never
came home and we must also never forget
the shameful cover-up that followed the
Hillsborough families have fought for
decades against obfuscation and lies to
get to the truth and everyone hoped that
Bishop John James report would be a
turning point and I welcome the work the
former Home Secretary did to commission
that report but it is five years on the
police rightly have said that it was
police failures that were the main cause
of the tragedy and police failures have
continued to blight this lives of
families ever since but to do so just
five years on is takes too long and it
makes it even more shameful to there is
still no government response to what has
happened to the Home Secretary yesterday
said it was because of active criminal
proceedings but those finished 18 months
ago and the work could have taken place
even while those proceedings were
ongoing it's September of 2021 the
government announced the response will
be published by the end of the year and
we are still waiting the Home Secretary
said yesterday the government was
engaging with families but what
engagement has taken place has the Home
Secretary met with them has she met with
the Bishops and I have to say where is
she today because previous home
secretaries have shown the respect to
the families and to the appalling ways
in which they have been wronged by being
here to respond and it is a devastating
failure of responsibility and respect to
them not to be here to respond
the key measures that were we need a
government response have been well known
on the duty of Canada on the public
Advocate on the elements of the
Hillsborough law the labor party stands
ready to support that law to get it into
statute so will the government now
commit to support that Hillsborough law
and to recognize what the bishop has
said about it being intolerable the pain
to those families not to have a response
the report was called the patronizing
disposition of unaccountable power would
he recognize that that is exactly what
this continued delay will feel like to
so many families and survivors now
Minister and well I entirely look agree
with the shadow home secretary's opening
comments about the appalling impact and
indeed of other members uh the appalling
impact this has had on the families of
those who so tragically lost their lives
I took my own son to a Crystal Palace
football game just a few weeks ago and
uh just thinking about how helpful it
must have been to be trapped in those
circumstances
um is is too a terrible thing to
contemplate and the police have
apologized as the shadow Home Secretary
said for the terrible failings uh that
took place on the day and and in the
Years
um subsequently it's right that they've
um apologized to the families and to the
country as well
um in relation to the timing I said
already
um there were legal proceedings ongoing
it has been 18 to 21 months since those
are concluded
um which is why since I was appointed
I've asked for this work to be sped up
and it will be concluded
um very rapidly but I do just want to
and it will respond to all of the points
in full
um but I do just want to to repeat the
point I made earlier
um but a number of things have happened
already she mentioned the independent
public Advocate we're a public
consultation has taken place which as
she will know from her own time in
government is generally speaking a
Prelude to
um action and on the question of
cooperating with and on the question of
cooperating with
um inquiries the statutory Professional
Standards for police Singh introduced in
um did introduce that requirement but
the response does need to cover all the
points and that will happen very soon
thank you Mr Speaker I listened with
great care to my right arm offense
statement but I do have to press him on
the independent public Advocate Point as
my my time to offend the member for
maidenhead said the ministry of Justice
was either the honor of leading I've
worked with her and The Honorable member
for Garten and hailwood is in a position
to go ahead with this policy the
consultation was five years ago what's
stopping the government from doing this
Ballista
well and thank you Mr Speaker I mean as
I um said before um to others including
the former prime minister
um the consultation has um as my
relatable friend said taken place
um the usual the usual processes in
government
um are going on well Christopher for the
government answering questions uh being
pressed by uh even by the labor MP for
Liverpool also vet Cooper Robert
Buckland and also Theresa May from his
own side as to why the government has
not responded Five Years on from the
report on the Hillsborough tragedy uh he
has said that since he has come into
position uh he has asked for the
government response to come out quickly
and it will come out he said this spring
couldn't be more specific than that but
he said that the families of the victims
will be consulted before the
government's response is given but he
said that there is a time frame it would
be happening this spring Theresa May
says saying vaguely she does not think
it is good enough she would like the
government to release its statement
sooner but that the latest on the
Hillsborough report now as Bishop joins
us said well away from the House of
Commons uh let's bring you these images
of Central London at the scene where
education workers are rallying against
controversial government anti-strike
laws it is also the biggest day of
industrial action in more than a decade
with teachers among others on strike
they are